welcome back this is the venture Pierrot
show we're taking your calls at eight
five five two three six thirty two
twenty eight that's eight five five two
three six 32:28 Sam and Massachusetts
are on the bench Shapiro she'll go for
it Sam I'm a new subscriber and I want
to thank you for everything you do
hey I appreciate it thank you all right
so I was just wondering today what you
think on the possibility of if we do
have a Joe Biden presidency what good
you think will come out of it and what
bad and what do you think will not
change at all so the bad that will come
out of it is very obvious on foreign
policy he will weaken the United States
he will attempt to reinstate the Iran
deal in the Middle East
he will go soft on China I mean he has
said over and over he doesn't think
China's a threat in any real way and so
you know I expect that he will go soft
on China again which would be a very
very bad move in terms of domestic
policy who will obviously time to raise
taxes that will be bad for the economy
who will reinstate regulations
particularly environmental regulations
but also tax-and-spend regulations he
will presumably attempt to go for a
public option in the in the medical
space if he has a Democratic majority in
the Senate it's possible he's able to
ram that through in the same way that
Nancy Pelosi rammed through Obamacare in
the first place although I doubt he'll
have enough of majority in the Senate to
actually get that passed that's the
downside the good side is that Biden
will foreclose Sanders which will be
good if Biden were to God forbid win the
presidency at the very least the
Democratic party doesn't swing out to
become the party of full-blown communism
which i think is horrible for the
country I don't think that Joe Biden
despite his best efforts to pretend to
be a Howard Zinn historian I don't think
he actually believes that kind of stuff
about the United States so that will be
fairly good I don't think that Biden is
inherently as offensive as somebody like
a Bernie Sanders to basic American
ideals I think that he's likely to be
doddering and annoying but not exactly
dangerous to America in the same way as
Bernie Sanders which is one of the
reasons why I think Trump wants to run
against Sanders because he can point at
Sanders single that guy's dangerous if
he points at Biden it's like more like
that guys that guy's not with us right
see not that those are I think the the
upsides and the downsides of a Biden
presidency I think that things come down
in the country a little bit mainly
because the Democrats will have won so
the Democrats don't go quite as nuts and
for Republicans well people would be
very ticked if from didn't win I think
that it's hard to get quite as ticked
about Biden winning as it would be about
Sanders winning right I mean they hit
again I don't mean he presents an
existential threat to the country in the
same way that
that's he'll be terrible don't get me
wrong I mean I just named all the
reasons I think he'd be worse than
trumpets I would not support Biden over
Trump in any case like at all but if it
Biden more to become president it would
be less damaging to the country than if
Sanders were to become president or
something so no those are sort of the
upsides and downsides by Biden I totally
agree with you on that and do you think
the Senate will change if Biden is on
the ticket versus if Bernie god forbid
does and you think the house is going to
turn Republican or how do you think
that's all good well I think that that
Sanders has no coattails at all and
maybe reverse coattails
I think if Biden you know were to win he
presumably would have some more
coattails he doesn't alienate moderates
and particularly suburban women in the
same way that Bernie does remember Trump
has some some vulnerabilities his
vulnerabilities particularly are with
minority communities and with young
people and with suburban women now young
people don't tend to vote right Bernie
was really counting on young people
turning out to vote but he does really
poorly does Bernie with minority
audiences and he does really really
poorly with suburban women and so those
are audiences that could theoretically
turn back to Trump which is why Trump
wants Bernie is the nominee Biden is
much more much more uh I would say
durable with with minority audiences
with suburban women he's significantly
more durable with young people he
doesn't do anything but young people are
hard to hang your hat on so this is why
Biden is a stronger candidate in a
general election
then then Trump I mean that nothing
Trump then then Sanders it's also why
Biden happens to have a broader map
right Biden is gonna challenge in states
like Pennsylvania he will challenge in
Wisconsin he will challenge in Florida
for example he has a much broader map he
doesn't have to win quite as many states
that are on tenterhooks as Bernie
Sanders so he's got some strengths as a
candidate just because he is not
offensive right I've been saying this
for a year the fact that ul Biden is a
dead person actually cuts in his favor
in a general election it makes the issue
about Trump as opposed to being about
Sanders yeah I agree I think if Biden
and Trump were there we go in a general
election
I think Trump's personality was what
would really hurt him in the general
election especially with purple states
yeah I mean again I think that that
Biden is a harder run for Trump he is
I'm Adan's Haman's for a long time
doesn't mean Trump wouldn't beat him it
doesn't mean it's a harder run Sam
really appreciate the call Rachel and
Oregon you're on the bench Parashar go
for it Rachel
thank you very hard question so it's I
mean things are becoming more and more
political as the years go on I think due
to social media inside the 13 year olds
and 11 year old and my my sixth grader
my eleven year old was asked in class
how they felt about Trump you know do
they want him as the president you know
for the next election I look like that
and you know my son's answer was well it
doesn't affect me and you know I kinda
had a word with him I was like actually
it kind of does
because you know these are the
candidates and their dad happens to be a
Bernie Sanders be understand and is
gonna vote for him and so we had a
discussion on the differences between a
fun space president or Sanders thinks
becomes president and and we get what
age is really appropriate to really dive
into I guess the seriousness of politics
as a racially thing you know I've kids
who are who are six and and soon to be
four I'm gonna have another one on the
way maybe like this very moment and and
then and my my and my answer is that as
the questions arise you have to deal
with it I mean really I've had my
daughter asked me specific questions
about politics because and she's six
right questions not that she hears in
school but like for example we were
reading about poram the other day which
is a holiday that's coming up next week
for Jews it talks about Esther and
Mordecai and and sort of the Persian
Empire and she said could we go to
Shushan which is one of the cities
mentioned in the mohenjo-daro so I have
to explain to her why the Iranian regime
is bad like in very very basic terms as
questions arise you answer them in the
most honest way possible that's taking
your kids seriously I think that is
different than sort of foisting politics
on them but values our politics you
teach your kids valleys and that is
going to have political ramifications
Rachel and that starts from the earliest
age they're asking questions about
values which do have political
ramifications Rachel really appreciate
the call today is Super Tuesday so this
evening we're going to find out whether
Joe mentum is real or a figment of
imagination is the bench Bureau show